why hello there internet i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
today is june 3rd 2022. it's friday we
are live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv share subscribe and tap that
notification bell if you have not uh
we've got a locals community q a today
but before i get to that you know i've
been talking a lot about elon musk
lately and as i always say it's like we
shouldn't be doing hero worship with
anyone he is as flawed as any of us but
the guy is an individual fighting the
system and that is good one two three
there you go that is good as far as i'm
concerned and it's not just that he's
fighting this administration on
inflation and he's actually building
things like electric cars and rockets
all that stuff
even now uh he is fighting within his
own company to get people to actually go
back to work two and a half years
basically after the beginning of this
pandemic this scam demik whatever you
want to call it this covid nonsense
there are still a tremendous amount of
people that are basically only working
from home only working from home because
often they're not working doing
everything through zoom we know this is
crushing creativity because when you're
actually in a room with someone and a
bunch of people you might have a better
chance through a little bit of human
interaction and reading people's faces
and actually being there in the tension
of being with people uh that it might
actually burst forth new ideas and
everything else instead of just keeping
everyone in little boxes so the guy
wants his people back in the office and
he's laying down the law and i thought
this was super interesting here we've
got some info from the new york post
elon musk ordered tesla staffers back
into the office full time on tuesday and
invited employees who weren't happy to
pack up and pretend to work somewhere
else in a terse email sent to corporate
tesla staffers musk wrote that anyone
who wishes to do remote work must be in
the office for a minimum and i mean
minimum
of 40 hours per week or depart tesla
this is less than we ask of factory
workers if there are particularly
exceptional contributors for whom this
is impossible i will review and approve
those exceptions directly musk added
moreover the office must be a main tesla
office not a remote branch office
unrelated to the job duties screenshots
of musk's email circulated on twitter
tuesday in response to a twitter user
who asks musk for his response to any
tesla employees who think in-person work
is an antiquated concept musk once again
bashed remote workers they should
pretend to work somewhere else
musk said you know the reason that i
think this is so great is not that
people cannot work remotely and not that
certain people have health issues or
other concerns or everything else but
all of this has led to a serious
breakdown of society at so many levels
you know after traveling a lot over the
last two months on tour and going to
major cities chicago denver new york etc
and seeing the midtowns of these cities
that once were were humming and and
jam-packed all the time and you'd see
people everywhere in restaurants and
people on sidewalks and all that stuff
to see the sort of urban decay that's
going on in all of these places uh is
pretty awful it's it's awful for a city
it's awful for a society it's awful for
our psyche which is perhaps why so many
people feel so disconnected with
everything the other part that i think
about uh that i think is so great about
this is that he's saying the buck stops
with me right like we don't have enough
people
in society these days who are like
enough is enough enough is enough we had
two and a half years of this and now
we're going to get back to normal not a
new normal how about the old normal it
was pretty good we're going to get back
to that and that he's saying he
personally will review the cases if
people really feel they cannot go back
to office and he's just making no
excuses we're in an endless time of
excuses and nonsense and that slowed
dissent to hell and he's just saying
enough is enough and i think that that
is absolutely fantastic and that's all i
think about that all right let's get to
some reubenreport.locals.com
q and a
ben says justin trudeau is making papa
castro proud in other news california
just got dumber did you hear a san
francisco school district is going to
ban the word chief from job titles
because of racism against indians yes i
did hear that california is a dump san
francisco is a [ __ ] you must leave
if you live there and you would like to
remain part of a functioning society and
raise a family of people who are sane
and productive on this pale blue dot
yeah it's just done it's done for now
will a phoenix rise from the ashes of
california one day perhaps but it is
going to re-elect gavin newsom again uh
the mayor london breed i think is her
name she just announced she's putting
more money into getting trans homeless
people off the streets regular homeless
people you can stay there we're going to
get trans people these people are
horrible they don't prosecute crime they
put more drug addicts on the street they
give drugs to people
get your and then they're worried about
the word chief if that's causing racism
it's like good god get help
gellersh says with the push by schools
to indoctrinate kids into racial and
sexuality issues daily wire kids is
creating dw kids is locals similarly
recruiting people to make kid centric
content so first of all if you don't
know what he's referring to there uh the
daily wire is putting a hundred
million dollars into kids programming
that's absolutely incredible 100 million
bucks on top of that prageru as you may
know they have a huge kids programming
section right now prageru kids and
that's absolutely blowing up uh yes 100
one of the next things that locals and
rumble are going to be working on are
building out these verticals so that
they're that we will be focused on
gaming initiatives and the politics
initiatives and
the kids initiatives and all of those
things uh so we're on boarding all sorts
of people and we'll hopefully have some
announcements on that front but yeah
it's like let the old things burn get
rid of disney plus get rid of
nickelodeon and all of this woke
nonsense and let's build new things
isn't that isn't that sweet
mark says
are you bummed that the heat lost to the
celtics or have you been ignoring the
nba i got to tell you i had a moment the
other day
so i'm at a restaurant and somebody
comes up to me a fan comes up to me and
he says hi and we're talking for a
little bit and he's like oh man you know
you're in miami and i know you're so
happy and you're loving florida and
miami's great and he's like you must be
so psyched about the heat and i did not
even realize fully that it was the nba
playoffs i didn't know the heat were in
it if you would have told me the heat
had 10 wins this season i wouldn't
believe that i don't know what the hell
is going on
i would like the nba to come out of the
woke stupor and hopefully it will one
day but no so i guess apparently the
celtics are going to the finals if i'm
if i'm reading this correctly or at
least the eastern conference finals
wherever they're at right now uh so good
for the boston celtics i suppose and i'm
sorry to hear that for the good people
of miami who deserve a winner but i just
don't care about the nba anymore i just
don't care
oferb says california is asking that
people not charge their electric
vehicles this summer because the system
cannot produce enough electricity to
handle the expected demand for air
conditioning can california ever recover
will the voters left in cali come to
their senses i mean i sort of referenced
this earlier look there are some
decent people
in california you know michael
shellenberger who i've had on the show
is running for governor against newsome
he's not going to win obviously but he's
trying to fight and fighting the good
fight is worthy and everyone should have
a time in their life when they fight
that good fight but i don't think you
have to spend your whole life fighting
that good fight from the same position
so i lived in cali i fought the good
fight i pushed for that recall i
campaigned with larry elder and then i
just said enough is enough they audited
me i thought this place is going to [ __ ]
i just don't want anything to do with it
anymore
but it's not that i gave up the good
fight i now fight the good fight here
from high ground here in florida
florida's happens to be very flat but
i'm fighting it from metaphoric high
ground where there's a place that is
there is a castle worth saving that can
be saved here in califor florida and
that's what i'm interested in doing and
it feels a lot better and i think i've
i've survived and thrived to borrow from
the subtitle of my most recent book um
so cali i just think callie is screwed
for now there'll be pockets there's
pockets in oc shout out to all my people
in brea who come to all my stand-up
shows
there are pockets
northern cali has a little more of a
libertarian spirit but the machinery it
is so deeply corrupt the voting rolls
are so screwed up
everything is so highly taxed and think
of think about it this way
think of all of the people the hun i
think around 200 000 people if not more
who fled california in the last two
years these are productive people who
are good members of society for the most
part they took their families their jobs
and everything else even if you take my
team my handful of people who were all
good members of society paying their
rents paying their mortgages paying car
payments going out to dinners spending
money in the community being good
neighbors going to church blah blah blah
blah blah and we all just got the hell
out over time that actually hurts los
angeles it hurts california and i just
think it ain't coming back anytime soon
kevin says did you get any inspiring
messages from jordan on tuesday night
that you'd like to share with the
community so we could throw that picture
up of jordan and i from uh from dinner
the other night yeah we had dinner just
the two of us in miami he was here for a
couple days before he jumps off and
continues his tour in europe which he's
uh he's super psyched to do you know we
had about three hours we had about three
hours we did an early dinner it was a 5
30 dinner because you know it's tough
for jordan unfortunately it's one of the
catch-22s of
fame
it's very hard for jordan to go out to
dinner publicly because he gets mobbed
by people and he loves people and he's
he's kind and decent to everyone and
tries to give everyone time but if he
was to go out at
prime time dinner time it's like his
meal on it trust me i've been with him
many times for this uh you know the meal
gets overtaken by people coming up to
say hi and he never wants to be rude to
anyone and you know i get some version
of that you know if i go out to dinner
like someone two three four some i don't
know maybe a dozen people sometimes will
come up to me but it's not the level
that jordan's at so he's really had to
change his lifestyle because of this and
i think that there's a well he even
acknowledge it with me that's that's
something like it's his life now it's
it's his new life and i think sometimes
to some degree he longs for that old
life but anyway we had a three-hour
dinner we just had an absolute blast um
i don't want to talk about everything
that we talked about but we got into
some pretty deep personal and political
stuff and we are going to do a podcast
together live
in miami in july we're going to figure
it out we'll maybe post it across both
channels or something and we're really
going to try to get into some new ground
related to fatherhood related to
same-sex couples related to wokism and
the excesses of it but really try to
come we really hit some new things last
night that haven't been fully fleshed
out in public yet so uh i will kind of
leave it at that i will say one other
thing which was um he uh
he said something sort of very nice to
me about
my evolution and where things have gone
and that uh you know that he's proud to
have been a part of that so yeah that
was nice to hear uh mark says to fight
the evil klaus schwab
uh who's the head of the world economic
forum do you take james bond or austin
powers
oh boy uh you know i have to say i
watched the last uh bond movie what was
the last one no time to die pretty good
and i feel like that guy although it
didn't end well for him he could have uh
he could have taken out the klaus schwab
uh nick says since you still have
netflix to re-watch seinfeld have you
seen the new season of stranger things
or the dangerous new ricky gervais
special well first off conor can you get
me seinfeld on some sort of server we
have a server here can you get me all
the shows on the server so that i can
cancel netflix can you do that
okay connor will figure that out that's
number one uh number two i have not seen
the new gervase thing yet but i love
ricky gervais he's an actual comedian in
a time when comedy's pretty beaten up
although i do have to say i was quite
hilarious on the tour uh what was the
first part of that question it was ricky
to raise on the second part oh the
stranger things you know we watched the
first two seasons of stranger things and
i loved it and it's a real throwback to
goonies and sort of 80s a little bit of
ghostbustery but you know a little more
kids focus kind of stuff really loved it
we started watching season three
and i was sort of like just kind of been
there done that i'm guessing it's
probably good and you're probably
digging it so uh i had no problem with
it the music was great that the kids
were fun all that good stuff as i said
like the goonies heartstrings to me were
great that just
sort of like these kids like just on an
adventure i just kind of loved but i
just it just kind of petered out for me
there you go uh anya says do you think
some companies will resist the
temptation
to rainbow their logo and if so which
one well that's a good question because
everybody in the last two or three days
everybody's going full rainbow on
twitter mercedes-benz although they
worked with the nazis a long time ago
they're very rainbowy right now
every company's out there disney of
course they're all very rainbowy they
love diversity they love inclusion
they love tolerance except they're not
tolerant of other people but they love
tolerance of the people that they
pretend to be tolerant uh i don't know i
i'm guessing spacex ain't gonna throw up
a rainbow i'm guessing tesla ain't gonna
throw up a rainbow that would be nice by
the way all of that being said nobody
cares nobody cares and you idiots are
actually turning you're making good
people prejudice against gay people by
jamming this [ __ ] down their throats and
i don't mean that metaphorically or i do
mean it metaphorically kathy says do you
know which baby is biologically yours
and which is biologically david's will
you tell the boys ever so we do know
um i don't want to get into all the
considerations on how we made every
decision but i will broadly say that we
went with the strength of the embryos
that really was because they actually
grade the embryos in terms of strength
and their ability to survive and all of
those things um we're not going to tell
other people and i suspect over the
years that people will kind of figure it
out but our plan is not to tell other
people and will we tell the boys well
we're going to try to be as honest as we
can as parents and when the questions
come up we will try to
answer them as honestly as possible um
but in terms of other people
um we we're just going to let it be
raise the kids with an awful lot of love
and go from there
tony says as an ex-californian how do
you convince people in your new state
that you fled for freedom and that
you're here to help i see a lot of fear
that californians are going to turn
states blue but data in florida is
showing an influx of refugees and it's
turning more red yeah i've hit this a
couple of times i know so many people
here
and so many people come up to me when
i'm out that are new refugees here and
they're coming from new york they're
coming from connecticut of course
they're coming from cali uh they're
coming from all over the place and
they're coming here and
there is something different the covid
thing and then the the summer of
violence and the destruction of the
cities and the defunding the police all
of the crap of the last two years i
think it was so obvious
that this was happening because of
democrats because of progressives
because of these policies people really
know why they fled in the old days like
if you took
say 10 years ago someone's flea and cali
why would they flee in cali 10 years ago
it was purely on taxes it was purely on
taxes like i'm sick of paying this
amount of money so i'm moving and i'm
going to texas then you get to texas and
for some reason you that it doesn't
override in your brain it doesn't fully
connect so you get to texas and you
start voting for the same stupid things
it's different i can tell you it's very
different here in florida i can't speak
to exactly the the influx in
uh say tennessee or texas specifically
but here everyone i'm meeting an awful
lot of people from san francisco awful
lot of people from la they get what they
fled many many people saying i'm voting
republican for the first time and
it more than anything else like more
than the political part when you see how
many people are happy here and
functional here and out and about and
what that does to you on a day-to-day
basis when you're around it
and then when you connect that hopefully
to the politics part and you go oh there
is a connection between say keeping a
state open and funding the police and
having safe neighborhoods there's a
connection between all of that and kind
of being happy well hopefully you're
going to vote the right way so i make
sure i always tell my neighbors i'm here
to keep florida florida you got nothing
to worry about
leslie says how much does your faith
affect the forming of your political
and or policy opinions
well i wrote about this a little bit in
dopa in this book and then i expanded on
it a bit more and don't burn this
country but i would say that
you humans need to believe period
period that doesn't mean you can't have
a phase where you don't believe or you
can trick or that you can't trick
yourself or or
i want to word it right that you
i believe a certain amount of people can
trick themselves into thinking they
don't believe but i think belief is so
connected to what it is to be human to
be a fully functioning human that you
will believe in something whether you
believe it or not how about that
and and jordan peterson obviously talks
an awful lot about this and i think one
of the things that's one of the things
that's been really interesting over the
last couple years is that people of
faith and it doesn't matter the specific
faith doesn't matter that much actually
but people of faith who believe in
something else something eternal
something before us that is go that went
on before us and that is going to
continue after us
they've i've consistently found to be
way more tolerant and way more sane in
an insane time
the the people that didn't want to force
everyone to be injected that understood
what the role of government is uh that
wanted to make decisions for themselves
they generally were people of faith i
don't mean that they were all uh you
know bible thumping and going to church
every sunday or that they were all
yamaka wearing orthodox jews or they
were devout muslims but there was a
certain set of people who were just like
i believe in something else something
other than oh i pick up the new york
times and my god i have the bible handed
to me every day and here's what reality
is because it ain't reality so the
people who found all of their belief in
the nonsense of the day they pretty much
all went crazy because mainstream media
is designed and twitter and social media
is all designed to make you crazy so i
would say the for me
the more i've
entered that world the more i've
returned to some of my family's
traditions things like that cared about
holidays more i feel that it actually
has made me saner and as i said a few
weeks ago uh you know when when passover
which of course coincides with easter
when i was doing the passover seder with
my family it's like we're reading this
seder which is you know the story of the
hebrews leading
leaving egypt and and going to the
promised land going to israel thousands
and thousands of years ago and it's a
story of freedom and the fight for
freedom that takes place every
generation and it's like that makes a
hell of a lot more sense
than most of the nonsense coming out of
cnn and washington post and everything
else
taylor says will you be taking time off
when the babies come babies i mean since
they are arriving about a month apart
yeah so uh we got one due in august one
due in october i'm told my life is about
to significantly change
uh i do the august off the grid
situation so um at some point in august
baby one will arrive but we're gonna
we're getting the house in order now and
all that kind of stuff but my plan is to
be back uh you know right after labor
day for that first show the back on the
grid
show and then the show will continue as
is and you know i'm sure my life will
change to some degree in terms of
working and
taking care of kids and all of those
there's just no doubt that that's gonna
happen that that's gonna change um and
then for baby two because that's in
october um i may have to take off a
couple days around that um just
depending on you know uh
literally like just the logistical stuff
of what's gonna happen in terms of birth
and where we're going to be and all of
those things
but hopefully not too much time off that
would be my hope
joe says i've heard the new top gun film
is quite good have you seen it and heard
any feedback or have any feedback i have
not seen it yet but i have some america
loving friends that i have a text thread
with who really did dig it uh however i
have to say this is going to upset a lot
of people i did not love top gun
i did not love what do you think about
the top gun
you like the top gun you do you love the
top gun what's the deal with you in top
gun somebody in your family loves top uh
you didn't love it didn't somebody
anyway i know you gotta love top gun
goose
the other guy the guy in the plane
what's his name i get it uh you know the
song the motorcycle okay the sun going
down um
didn't love it little slow
i thought it was a little slow but i'm
hearing good things about the second one
and i will watch it and i heard it's
like it's not woke and it's kind of
almost fully pro-america so pretty good
pretty pretty good ian says how do you
maintain your sanity and relieve stress
over worrying for the fate of the
country i'm only 25 but i have an
uncertain feeling for the fate of the
union uh all right ian well look let me
tell you this i'll tell you what i tell
david all the time so david is usually
dealing with most of the sort of
day-to-day stuff in our lives we're
redoing stuff in the house right now we
have babies on the way
managing our employees like all the
stresses that happen on any given day
right and those are the things that
stress him and i get very little stress
out of those things but i am always
stressed about the bigger things in the
world or i don't want to call them
bigger but like sort of the more blue
sky or ephemeral things like iran could
get the bomb the communists might take
over america uh the end of freedom might
be here like those are the things that i
worry about where a certain set of
people worry about sort of the immediate
things in front of them i think that's
kind of why we work together as a as a
couple but i feel you but i would say
this as 25 year old if you're too
worried about those things i would say
step back from those things a little bit
there there is only so much you can do
to save the world um but to quote jordan
peterson it's like if you can get your
life in order clean your room first then
you can clean the world so if you have
some stuff to do to kind of get your
life in order which i'm sure you do at
25 years old and i do at 45 years old
and everyone watching this does one way
or another it's like if you can do that
a little bit more in your life then some
of the other stuff won't seem so crazy
it's also why i try to do the show the
way i do and i try to do some silly
stuff along the way and i try to make
you laugh and i always say it's like
when the best compliment that i can get
on this is hey dave you help you help me
stay sane or you made me laugh about the
news when everyone's trying to make me
miserable so the best way to change the
world is to change yourself in essence
and uh i suspect if you're watching this
show and you're in this community at 25
like you're kind of on the way but if i
really mean this like if
the day-to-day stuff hearing about
inflation and hearing about ukraine and
guns and everything else even if
watching me is not bringing you some
degree of joy or something then you
don't have to watch for for a little
while at least take a day off not not
too long here i mean but but i really do
mean that it's like there there's a
fight in the world that is always going
to go on right we didn't start the fire
right and and uh listen to the whole
billy joel song and it's kind of in
there this thing has been going on and
it's always going to go on and it does
feel it feels uncertain i guess that's
what it is more than anything else at 25
when i was 25 i thought the world felt
certain it was like there was a certain
order to the world that we felt was
going to continue you're growing up in a
world and especially at 25 now so you've
spent your early 20s in a world that
feels very
topsy-turvy right it's like it feels
like it's built on quicksand but there's
opportunity in that and that's the
chance for you because there's always a
way to build a better mousetrap there's
always a way to pave a new road and do
some new things and that's what you got
to figure out for yourself
and says dave is there one major
sentiment or feeling that you took away
from meeting with fans during the tour
yeah i really love you guys i have great
fans i really mean it it sounds cliche
and ridiculous but everybody everyone i
met huge smiles on everybody's faces a
lot of people wanted the one second hug
some people try for the two second hugs
some husbands gave the wife there one
second to get the two second or vice
versa
and it was just great being out there
laughing with people the sentiment
the sentiment was like and i would stop
sometimes in the middle of show to just
kind of get everyone to look around you
were in a room with jam you're in a
jam-packed room
with 500 other people that are all
laughing right now all having fun nobody
cares what color you are nobody cares
who you're sleeping with nobody cares
about any of that nonsense and that's
the america that we all had that we let
them take away from us and we got to get
it back and people people know that's
right we know we want to do it we know
we want to get it back and we just got
to do a little work to do it
that is all i got to say about that on
that note everybody have a great weekend
part two of my interview with dinesh
d'souza is up on youtube i think we'll
see what happens uh parts two and three
of my interview with nba star jonathan
isaac are up on youtube i'm pretty sure
they stayed up so have a great weekend
and we'll do it again on monday ciao
you